what's happened over the last five years
is really diving into what we know about
the brain and meditative states and
understanding that they're not all the
same that it depends on how you're using
your attention and what your intention
is and those two things change what
brainwaves are involved and in what
brain regions and so when we understand
that information then we can be much
more directed about what we're actually
trying to do boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host
silence akheon we are at consciousness
hackings awakened futures conference we
are now going to be talking to Jeff
Tarrant hello hey thanks for coming on
the show thanks for having me she ate it
very excited so your thought are the
neural meditation Institute yes and
neuro meditation is the application of
brain based principles to meditation
practices and you've you interestingly
have taught me that all meditation is
generally fall into one or more of four
categories focus mindfulness quiet mind
and open heart I love learning about
this and it definitely resonated with me
I'm excited to learn more about this so
why don't you give us a bit on who you
are and what you represent
sure so my my background is actually as
a counseling psychologist but most of
the work that I've done has been with
neurofeedback so measuring the brain
monitoring the brain and feeding back
information to teach people's brains to
be more flexible and adaptive but then I
also have a background in meditation and
so it's not a big stretch to see how
those two things could go together
they're both technologies in a way to
influence states of consciousness and so
what's happened over the last five years
is really diving into what we know about
the brain and meditative States and
understanding that they're not all the
same that it depends on how you're using
your attention and what your intention
is and those two things change what
brain waves are involved and in what
brain regions and so when we understand
that information then we can be much
more directed about what we're actually
trying to do okay so when did you first
have the
moment of okay attention and intention
and how this applies to meditation and
neurofeedback yeah interesting question
the reality of what happened was I was
just minding my own business doing my
thing and was invited to write a book
chapter in a neurofeedback book and I of
course said yes and my second question
was what do you want me to write about
and the editor said well whatever you
want to write about and I just
spontaneously said how about a neuro
meditation it just came out of my mouth
without me thinking about it and he said
great and so then I was like oh I guess
I need to figure this out
and so really became you know looking at
the research that's been done in the
field of neuroimaging and meditation and
there's just mountains of it and it
didn't take long to figure out that you
know other researchers have already
figured out that that really you can
isolate different styles of meditation
into a few different categories they
call them different things in the
research literature then what we call
them we tried to pick names that were a
little bit more user-friendly but when
you start to look at it it's pretty
clear that if you do and it makes sense
if you direct your attention in
different ways it's going to affect the
brain differently and so in some ways
it's very obvious when you sort of break
it down it's like well of course of
course all meditations aren't the same
because you know if you're doing a
concentration practice versus you know
something like Zen well that's very
different you're using your attention in
very different ways so it's gonna affect
the brain differently okay this so then
even after that chapter you were like
I'm gonna start an institute about it it
wasn't an immediate jump to there but
yes I wrote the book chapter and
initially my focus was on using
neurofeedback as a tool to help people
find these states of meditation and I
still do a lot of that you know you can
hook somebody up give them an auditory
signal that lets them know when their
brain is in the right meditative state
so it's kind of a super coach and so
that's what I started with and then very
quickly figured out that the principles
apply way beyond
just people who do neurofeedback and so
started teaching a workshop for a
company called pecci that they send
people around the country to do
continuing education workshops and so my
initial idea became this day-long
workshop which then became a book and
then at some point was like okay you
know it just kept getting bigger and
bigger and now it's an Institute feel as
though so many people that have
practiced any form of this inward
practice meditation have felt these
differences with with a focus or maybe a
heart centric exercise all right so
start unpacking some of this for us sure
yeah and so so the four styles you know
you I think you mentioned but you know
that that we work with our focus
mindfulness open heart and quiet mind
and so the focus practices almost
everyone who has done any kind of
meditation is familiar with that because
so many practices involve you know
focusing on the breath when your mind
wanders recognize that it wandered and
bring it back on track or a mantra or an
image of the Buddha and so what we know
is that if if the whole goal is to hold
your attention on a specific target and
don't let the mind wander and when it
wanders get it back well the brain is
pretty much doing the exact same thing
whether it's a word or phrase or an
image or the breath it's the intention
I'm holding my attention on one thing
and that's actually a very active
process we think of meditation as being
this quiet inward state but the reality
is that in some cases it's not taught to
sustain your attention on one target you
have to activate attention circuits in
your brain so it's not all quiet some
parts are quiet some parts are very
active sometimes we can be that battle
with the monkey mind of stop racing away
I'm for coming back to the focus okay
well right and actually so to give an
example of the brain regions focus is a
good one because it's fairly
straightforward
the frontal lobe and especially the
anterior cingulate
needs to be engaged for a focus
meditation it's involved in sustaining
attention and also discriminating
between thoughts and emotions so the
anterior cingulate is actually going to
be active during a focus meditation but
the default mode network in the back of
the brain which is the monkey mind has
to be quiet so you have to have both of
those things happening at the same time
this has to be active this has to be
quiet in order to be in a focus state
and so this is where it's important to
sort of look at the different brain
regions and and what's actually
happening then are you usually using an
EEG to view this yeah so if I'm working
with somebody individually or studying
it we use a 19:00 channel EEG and then
some specialized software called s
Loretta that allows us to extrapolate
from the surface into deeper brain
regions kind of like an MRI yeah yeah
well you see you can successfully take
the bio signals and process them to
extrapolate to the deeper areas right
okay and that's how you can tell like an
anterior cingulate exactly okay
interesting and so then with that you
see with focus that there needs to be a
focus as well as a quieting of the
monkey mind okay and then there's so
many other ones as well
okay mindfulness quiet mind and open
heart right how there's some overlap
with that focus in quiet mind a little
bit actually it's interesting that you
went to that well there is so this is
what I've found really interesting you
know the more you look at this you start
to see how they work together and the
similarities and the differences so with
focus your your holding your attention
on one thing with quiet mine you're
holding your attention on no things and
so it's basically the same so with focus
this is active this is quiet with quiet
mind this is quiet and this is quiet
so you basically drop this you keep this
drop this and so a lot of traditional
transcendental meditation practices
start with a focus they start with a
mantra as a focus meditation to settle
the mind and quiet things down
and over the course of the meditation
you let that focus go and you end up in
this quiet spacious awareness so what
they're doing is starting with focus
starting here and then dropping that out
over the course of the meditation it's
brilliant
yeah very clever yeah yeah yeah you get
really good at at just being with your
breath or with just being you're just
being right yeah just sort of you know
that sort of spacious awareness where
there's kind of not much going on
internally you know sometimes I when I'm
in that space sometimes it's almost like
blackness like you're aware that there
are some little thoughts or images
floating around out here but you're not
really tuning into any of them and so
it's just this big openness you know
interesting so it's almost as though all
of the thought potentials exist but
you're not collapsing any of those right
staying in this yeah I like that that's
sort of quantum kind of way of talking
about it you know I was like oh yeah you
know you're not engaging with any of
them they're kind of all floating out
there but you're not you're not giving
them any energy interesting and then
when you so you see on the neurofeedback
side there's what does the activity look
like I've gone a completely quiet level
for for a quiet mind practice the brain
pattern you see is significant increases
of alpha-1 so eight to 10 Hertz
specifically so a lot of times so it's
funny because traditionally we've talked
about meditation being an alpha state
and the reality is that the other
meditation styles don't really engage
alpha much it's really the quiet mind
and it's and it's not the whole band of
alpha it's just the low band of alpha
eight to ten Hertz and you know that is
a very when there's a lot of 8 to 10
Hertz the brain is kind of like at rest
there's there's nothing really active
going on and so it makes sense when you
get into the faster frequencies of alpha
the brain can actually be it's in a more
alert stage where it's kind of looking
for something to do
so it's not quite the same in terms of
being in just arrested open awareness
and then is the focus state more towards
that higher alpha or a beta or where's
the focus state focus is actually gamma
its gamma oh yeah right
gamma up in the front and then alpha one
in the back so this is quiet and this is
engaged at its most profound flow state
right which is where you see that gamma
sometimes if people are efforting too
hard so you see this with a lot of
beginning meditators where they're doing
a focus meditation and they're trying
really hard you know like I'm I'm
focused on my breath and then it's not
gam huh then it's more like a beta or a
beta to where they're kind of pushing a
little bit and you'll see that in the
research too sometimes they'll see beta
2 rather than gamma and my theory is
that that's what's happening is people
are pushing but when you're in that
effortless attention holding your
attention on one thing but you're not
forcing it more like you'll see in an
expert
that's where you got that gamma so
that's why we want to encourage that
because you're not you're not pushing so
hard ok and then in and then in in just
in general I'm curious from a
neuroscientific perspective as we go
into open heart and mindfulness is this
just an overall would we say a decrease
in neural activity versus actually doing
a like a task where you're deeply
engaged like if we were to stand up and
move these chairs out of the room right
now there would be would we be engaging
significantly more or even the
conversation we're having right now
where we'd be engaging significantly
more neural infrastructure than when we
are simply in a process of doing the
quiet mind yeah in quiet mind pretty
much in a perfect quiet mind state
pretty much nothing is engaged now
that's hard to get into and it's really
hard to sustain and so that's one of the
things we try to help people
we also take a very practical approach
to try to help people understand what
these states are like because people
have a lot of myths and false ideas
about what it means to meditate and what
it means to be in these states to a
point that it's unachievable when they
give up the reality is that for most
people they can get into acquire mind
state but it's it's for just
microseconds correct and so to help
people understand that it's like you can
do this the idea is to learn how to sort
of expand that state you know so yes
there's moments where it's quiet and
there's nothing going on
so can you learn to kind of move into
that space and just be there and yeah
thoughts are gonna come up and your
minds gonna go do something else and
that's that's normal it's just like a
focus meditation you're focused on
something and then the mind gets
distracted and so you learn to go back
well in quiet mind it's like the mind
can be quiet but an empty and then it
gets distracted and you go back and so
but in that state yeah not much is going
on the whole brain is pretty darn quiet
we frequently mentioned that it's
critical to take things from perspective
we don't just walk out and start
shooting three-pointers and draining all
of them right away right it takes a long
time to become really good so when you
get the very small taste of a window of
quiet mind then we practice more and
more we get better at it is there is
there also a visible reduction in the
amount of glucose that the brain is
consuming as well yeah and I haven't
looked as carefully at you know the
studies with the glucose metabolism or
brain blood flow patterns things like
that mostly because my area is an EEG
yeah okay but yes in general when you
have an increase of alpha especially
alpha one you have a decreased you know
brain blood flow you have decreased
glucose metabolism and so yeah probably
healthy to just stretch our minds into
these extremes on the on the spectrum of
so that they can return to homeostasis
but
it's yeah and just to experience
different states of awareness in general
rather than just the simple like 99.99%
of the time just being in that state of
I'm engaged with something all the time
right yeah yeah okay so let's let's
unpack some of the other states my
getting this yep okay so and so
mindfulness were you know obviously
that's a hot term at the moment you know
and sort of everybody's talking about
mindfulness and so we're very careful
about how we talk about it because
everybody's using that term to mean
anything at everything and so we define
it very carefully to talk about you know
you're you're still paying attention but
you're paying attention in a very gentle
soft way to whatever's happening in the
present moment so you're tuning into
your thoughts and your emotions and your
bodily sensations in a way that you're
not grasping for anything you're not
pushing anything away you're tuning into
it allowing whatever it is to be there
without judgment you know so when you
start to define it you can see it's
actually a very specific way of paying
attention it's not just this random it
doesn't mean relaxation that doesn't
mean quiet mind it doesn't mean focus
and so you know we use the definition
that Jon kabat-zinn uses who you know
founder of mindfulness based stress
reduction and it's also consistent with
the research that they defined it as
open monitoring in the research you'll
often hear them use that term open
monitoring same thing and this is
another problem you look at the research
and people are using all kinds of terms
to mean kind of the same thing and so
you have to really dive in to see well
what does that mean when they say open
monitoring and when they define it it's
like well that's that's mindfulness so
we are using the term mindfulness but
we're very careful to define what that
means I like how you said gentle so you
say keeping this gentle sort of pace
with each moment that's coming and being
with feelings that emerge and just being
aware and gentle with them right yeah
acknowledging them letting them be there
giving them
some space and then letting them go
which is of course the trick
rather than the dwelling vert welling in
and kind of turning it into a story
getting hooked into it sure you know so
it's this it's very much this observer
mode of shifting into a state where
you're you're you're simply observing
what's happening with yourself and
around you and you know in your
interactions interesting okay could one
say that a focus state could be
something like if we were to be in
conversation right now is this a focus
day if we were to say hey let's move
these chairs out of the room is that a
focus if we're eating food and just
focused on eating food are those focus
states it depends it depends a little
bit and this is where it gets tricky
because a lot of meditations whatever
they call them you know whatever they're
called will often kind of go back and
forth between a focus and a mindfulness
kind of pattern so most meditations
aren't pure now some of them are if
you're just sitting watching your breath
and that's it that's another thing that
exists in the world that's what that's
clearly a focus meditation you know if
you're doing something like a body scan
right that's clearly falls into more of
a mindfulness kind of a category um you
know but there's elements of focus with
a body scan you know you're paying
attention to your toes you know but it's
it's kind of the way you're paying
attention to it so this is where that
how you're directing your attention and
what your intention is that those two
things become really critical and
there's some soft lines between those
different states in fact what a lot of
people will do with the mindfulness
meditation is they begin with the breath
and then when the mind wanders you know
they go and kind of explore that Oh
interesting
my thoughts are doing this Oh
interesting my bodies are nursing and
then they go back to the breath it's
usually what I don't eat and I didn't I
try and play across all of those though
right because then there's the heart yes
that one's very interesting and yeah and
even
the absolute quiet mind it's fun to be
able to play across all of these like
it's fun actually being able to take
you've made a taxonomy yeah where most
of the time it's either like mindfulness
baby or meditation yeah and it's just
done like that and then it's like what
do you mean it's so hard like sometimes
we we have that similar thing happen on
the show and we're talking about a
specific field of biology or of AI or of
when we ask if we're in a simulation you
know sometimes people feel like you know
what do you mean by you know that so
it's really great to have a taxonomy and
breakdown of these things what's what's
the what's the then the neural feedback
that you're mapping or during the
mindfulness so that's an interesting one
we've recently kind of upgraded the way
that we use neurofeedback with
mindfulness that was always the
trickiest one and partially because some
of the research literature shows
opposing things with mindfulness and so
it took me a while scratching my head
and reading through this and going like
this makes no sense
some of them would talk about a decrease
in gamma some will talk about an
increase in gamma and it's like this
doesn't make any sense
so I finally sort of got to a point of
understanding that there's actually kind
of a couple of subdivisions of
mindfulness and one I'm starting to use
the term sort of a thoughtless awareness
versus a thoughtful awareness so for
example a body scan it's a thoughtful
awareness right you're you're directing
your attention you're saying go to my
toes go to the bottom of my feet go to
my ankles but you're noticing what's
happening in the moment but it's a
guided your guiding your attention on
the course and so the brain does
something a little bit different as
opposed to I'm just sitting back total
observer mode just whatever floats
through my awareness that's what I
noticed you know the whole thing about
the clouds floating across the sky right
you know like you're noticing your
thoughts as if they're clouds and it's
like oh that's interesting there's a
thought oh okay
see you later
our that you know the leaves floating
down a stream like that's more of us
thought less awareness you're not
guiding it you're just allowing whatever
emerges to be there for a moment and
then letting it go and so it's a
slightly different pattern and so um so
we've designed two different approaches
based on what what way you're kind of
engaging with mindfulness and is a are
both thought less awareness and
thoughtful awareness mindfulness I think
so and thoughtful awareness maybe more
focus there's definitely a little bit
more of a focus involved because you're
directing your attention but it's now on
one thing you know you're shifting
you're moving it around you know and
you're allowing space for things you
know but with focus you're not you know
there's no room for anything if you're
not focused on that one target then
you're off track um what are you seeing
then with the neural feedback what do
you see right with the mindfulness yeah
yeah so there's a couple of patterns
that will emerge so one is you'll see
something called frontal midline theta
so back to that anterior cingulate
instead of gamma like we see with focus
you see theta but it's a special form of
theta called frontal midline theta and
so it is involved in some cognitive
processes but in a very soft gentle way
which again makes perfect sense you know
you're paying attention but you're
paying attention that's very easy soft
it's not this kind of laser focus you
know you'll also see the salience
network of the brain get involved
because the salience network of course
is involved in paying attention to
what's important right now
so the salience network that'll be gamma
is that also an anterior so you know
that's going to be the salience we
usually look well the anterior cingulate
is part of the salience network but the
insula and so uh is also part of this
those two are the biggies for the
salience network so there's a
communication that's kind
determining what's most salient to pay
most attention to correct so we
sometimes we bring that in and then we
bring the default mode Network in and
that's the one that gets a little tricky
with thoughtful versus thoughtless
because if you're actually if you're
doing a thoughtful meditation you're
actually activating the default mode
network because you're paying attention
to yourself which is what the default
mode Network does it's like a reflective
awareness so you'll actually activate
the default mode Network whereas a
thoughtless
it quiets it down that's why you see
those sometimes it increases gamma
sometimes it decreases gamma is this
like well how are you using the default
mode network is it are you engaging it
and sort of a reflective awareness or
are you like so passive that you're not
even engaging with anything if that
makes sense yeah this is you're starting
to really showcase the complexity when
you're getting into it yeah yeah but now
you're really in the weeds of how these
things can have some Venn diagram
overlaps but how they are also like you
said when you're reading this literature
some say that you have a gamma
activation gamma-d critiquing or
decreasing it's just like well which one
is it and yeah and as the tools the
neurofeedback tools get better
hopefully non-invasively maybe even
invasively but in a way that doesn't
actually penetrate right the cranium
there's so many ways things to explore
maybe we can talk about that at the end
let's do the open heart as well open
heart yeah my favorite probably yeah
this one's this one's fascinating
actually I does this have any
electrocardiogram ECG involved we have
not brought that in well I can't I
shouldn't say that exactly so even
though I focus on you know neurofeedback
you know we use other tech as well and
sometimes I'll actually just use heart
rate variability biofeedback as a tool
with these you can actually use heart
rate variability biofeedback
heart math you can actually use that
with focus with mindfulness and with
open heart and it works great for all of
them you know if you're familiar with
the heart math and what they're up to
you know they focus on positive
emotional states they focus on
appreciation as a way to get the heart
into a coherent pattern and so it's like
well guess what if you do a loving
kindness compassion meditation guess
what's going to happen you know you're
gonna shift into a more coherent heart
space so you know we do use heart rate
variability we usually don't tie them
together because it's just a lot of
information and it's hard for people as
it is to use the information in a way
without getting kind of hooked into it
you know use it as a support rather than
it pulling them out of state that's a
whole learning process in and of itself
and so adding too many things makes it
too tricky for people because they the
the you know the logical part of the
brain wants to understand what's going
on and wants to think about it and wants
to analyze it instead of just being in
the meditation but the but to answer
your original question you know so the
the open heart meditation there's a
couple of patterns involved there one of
them is frontal asymmetry may be proven
erro feedback let's also yeah open heart
okay
yes teach us some very compassion love
gratitude these types of exactly and
that's why we decided to go with that
term instead of calling it loving
kindness compassion which again is what
most of the research literature that's
what they focus on and you'll see it
even abbreviated LK - see in their
research loving kindness compassion and
oh and that's what most of it is around
but again that's still a huge category
there's a lot of ways you can do
loving-kindness and compassion
most of them are kind of like the
Buddhist kind of meta kind of practice
you know where you're imagining a loved
one let's say and you're sending them
loving kindness phrases you know may you
be happy may you be safe may you be
filled with joy whatever and so but we
wanted to also include things like
gratitude
forgiveness and other positive emotional
states that are used in different
meditations because the reality is again
you know if you're if the intention of
the meditation is to activate a positive
emotional state and then do something
with it send it to you send it to myself
send it to the world the brain pretty
much is doing the same thing and so we
don't have to get so specific and say oh
well Metta is different than gratitude
it's like hmm not really like we can
actually target a couple of different
patterns and they're all gonna do a
similar thing so open heart is our
umbrella to umbrella term okay cool and
then when and this one is definitely one
of the favorites it's just it definitely
raises the vibes it feels so good
and it's a it's actually a critical
thing to do when we wake up in the
morning when we go to bed at night and
even throughout the day totally yeah
yeah okay so then what are we seeing on
the neurofeedback side of things so
there's two patterns that we really look
at one is the frontal asymmetry and so
it's a well known pattern Richie
Davidson actually was a pioneer with
this and he's at the University of
Wisconsin and has done a lot of brain
imaging with the Tibetan monks works
with the Dalai Lama and some of his
earlier work was focused on looking at
activation patterns left versus right in
the front and when people are in a more
positive approach state the left sides
more active and when people are in a
more negative pessimistic withdrawal
state the right sides more active and so
you know we can mesh that's a very easy
thing to measure that we're actually
doing that with the muse headband we're
using the muse headband and we
reprogrammed it to look at that frontal
asymmetry it's an easy way to kind of do
that but so that's one thing we want to
look at what's up with that how we've
known that for a while it's just 3040
years and just in this asymmetry in the
in the
farlow in the frontal lobe yeah that
just the left side when you are doing
gratitude and compassion eyes is just
active and the and when you're feeling
not that
yep the right side becomes more active
yeah well and so you know everybody's
got a different baseline so you know you
can measure somebody's baseline and if
they tend to be more depressed you're
gonna see that right side just at
baseline be more yeah more harsher and
people who are always happy if you
measure them they're gonna be hanging
out on the left but you know state
situations change that you know so if
you think about you know Golden State
beat in Portland
you know you know probably your left
side is gonna light up you know or you
think about chocolate chip cookies you
know the left side is gonna light up but
it's gonna be temporary right you know
you're like wow you're thinking of
something happy the left side lights up
but then when you stop you're gonna go
back to your baseline and then when you
may be getting more an anxious thought
or something than the right side exactly
so what we're trying to do is kind of
almost retrain the brain and so like in
a similar way with neurofeedback if in
fact that's how I learned about this was
a neurofeedback land because this is the
standard protocol for somebody with
depression is to reward the left side
and inhibit the right side Wow and that
can be done now with transcranial
stimulation right exactly transcranial
direct current is one of the main
protocols you put the a note on the left
you put the cathode on the right and
it's doing exactly the same thing so so
yeah there's a lot of different
technologies that that can do that we
can we can is that is that is this
becoming more and more mainstream to to
just figure out ways to suppress that
that right side and activate that left
side of the frontal lobe yeah um you
know and for me what's important is that
now there is research showing that
simply activating the left can't have
positive effects for me it's it's
important to tie it to a gratitude
practice or loving-kindness because the
the issue I think we get into sometimes
with tech using tech with meditation is
making the mistake of thinking that just
because you're increasing gamma for
example that that's putting you in a
higher state and it's like well you know
elevated gamma is also associated with
Alzheimer's so it's like just because
you're raising your gamma doesn't
necessarily mean you're an expert
meditator you know it's like it has to
be in the context it has to be in the
right context tied in with some of the
open heart
exactly umbrella so even though the
research does show activating the left
seems to be a positive thing think about
it this way so the left side can also be
activated for for any kind of approach
motivation so moving towards something
so if you think about it that way
actually being angry and aggressive
could actually activate the left because
you're you're you're moving toward
something you're approaching something
for me it feels really important to tie
them together that the tech isn't a
substitute it's a it's a tool it's a
supplement to assist in the process but
you still have to get your own mind in
the right place okay couple power round
thoughts first is what else did you see
on neurofeedback on open heart mm-hmm
yeah the right insula so we talked about
the salience network but the insula is
also involved in emotion as well as
empathy and especially the right side
because the right side is a more body
based so like when you feel something in
your body so you know like when your
heart is activated you feel it in your
heart that's the right insula the left
sides more cognitive if the left sides
more like you're thinking about a
feeling the right sides more like you're
feeling no feeling so we usually want
that right side you know that's where
the magic happens if people can activate
that right side I mean you'll you know
I've had this happen many times and
workshops where people are just like
crying and I'm like yeah I always feel
I'm like oh you know are you okay and
they're just like filled with joy you
know and they're like feeling it and so
it's really intense you know
if you can get that going and then keep
it going so that's the other biggie is
keeping it going is it is it really that
this kind of black and white between
right and Scylla being more on the
feeling the deep emotion and empathy and
the left side being more about thinking
collect and so on I I mean I've seen it
pretty much clear as day you know it's
so crazy thinking about something as
complex as the you know billions of
nerve to be so black and white
potentially on a left insula versus
right yeah that's so great I'm sure
there's wiggle room you know but yeah
but literally if I'm monitoring
somebody's brain while they're doing a
meditation and I'm monitoring the to
insulate at the same time and you see
what's happening there I can pretty much
tell you know if the lights if the left
sides lit up and the right snot and I
interrupt them and I go what's going on
and they describe what's going on it's
it's a cognitive process yeah yeah you
know and if the right sides lit up you
know you know they're into it they're
they're in the body
yeah right okay okay
okay some other power thoughts on the
way is okay what are you what are you
doing with the neuro meditation
Institute so people come in to a
physical location and then work with you
teach us about that what's what's
happening sure actually we do a few
different things we were doing a lot of
classes and workshops at your physical
some of them are physical location we
also do in Eugene Oregon in Eugene
Oregon right okay cool we also do
workshops at other places so I just got
back from my worka we did a workshop
there where it's in Spain it's an island
off the coast of Spain sweet yeah so you
do kind of workshops or in different
places around the world that's right
come to as well exactly okay yeah hoping
to do one in San Francisco soon cool
it's time to happen right yeah let's do
it and uh you know going to Germany in
October so we do a lot of classes and
workshops and then yes work with
individuals
and so the individual work can take a
lot of different forms typically it will
involve some form of a EG monitoring and
coaching so it's for me it's it's a
two-step process like yes we're using
technology but you know I'm also kind of
serving as a meditation coach at the
same time so it's like they're getting
information but then I have to find out
like so what's going on and connect it
to what I'm saying from the EEG so that
I can say try this it seems like you're
getting stuck on this thing over here
try this let's see if this works better
so the idea is not that they have to
come in and get hooked up every time
they meditate the idea is for them to
learn what it feels like to be in the
right state the state they're trying to
get into so that when they go home and
practice they kind of know what they're
looking for yeah and then to come back
and refine that new Act there's the
closed loop feedback right there getting
to make the iterative change that they
need to get to the states that they want
to get to right and then what about the
the the feedback that comes in for them
to potentially take you also out of the
equation that they can then have a
feedback like a like the Mew system
where I have a visual cue or an audio
cue that that shows them oh you have the
the Thunder is striking and the birds
are doing their thing okay yeah yeah and
it tells you if you're focused or if
you're not on the parts that you're
supposed to be right so so let me just
clarify are you asking like what kind of
feedback I give in session or like what
they can use at home let's do both okay
yeah so we I use predominantly I use a
music track as feedback so I can link
the volume of the music to their success
so we'll play some ambient background
meditation music right that's not
overpowering it doesn't have a strong
rhythm but it's kind of supportive of a
meditative state kind of like we just
did this morning in the in the cacao
ceremony right there's this you know
certain music can kind of help you
but then and so it's always playing but
if your minds wandering and you're off
track the volumes really low and so
that's your cue like oh I'm not on track
and once you get into the correct state
the volume increases to a certain level
so again it's your cue like oh I'm there
and so what happens then is as soon as
the mind wanders for example that music
drops out and that's an instant cue
they're like oh whoa what happened and
then are you manually doing this or have
you already made the algorithms that can
just detect it and then cue the music to
go down or up in volume right it's a
little bit of both so I have to
determine where to put the thresholds
for whatever I'm monitoring and so that
I have to do manually because
everybody's different you know if we
looked at your brain versus my brain
they're gonna behave differently because
we're different people so usually in the
first couple of minutes I can figure out
where to put the thresholds and then I
can just leave it alone because you know
really what we're wanting the person to
do is learn how to get into those states
so I don't want to keep moving
thresholds around you know I want to get
them set where I think it's going to
give them accurate information about
their internal state and then let them
find it you know and so I've had it at
times where people are sit there for
three minutes and get no feedback and
from a traditional neural feedback
perspective that makes no sense and in
fact neurofeedback people have a hard
time with this like you're not giving
them any feedback and I'm like right
because they're not in the right state
why would I give you positive feedback I
bet why would I be saying you're doing
it right when you're not doing it right
so instead what I want to do like if
they're not finding it then that's where
the coaching comes in you know to stop
them and go I'm watching the what's
happening in their brain and to stop and
go like tell me what's going on let me
give you let's try a couple of other
things because it seems like you're kind
of struggling with this and so I give
them some ideas some suggestions some
tips and tools they try it again
and you know we help them kind of find
it on their own okay and then when they
go back home then they're able to what's
the feedback mechanism that they use
right so when they so partial
hopefully what what we want to happen is
that they don't actually need something
external that it becomes an internal
barometer excellent so again kind of
like using the heart rate variability if
you do it enough you know if you're in a
state of coherence you don't need the
equipment anymore that's right you know
you just go on there yeah and so that's
what we want is you told your syncing
three you can tell whether you're
syncing or not you know that's what we
want is people to have that internal
sensitivity but there's lots of you know
we use audio-visual and treatment we use
transcranial direct current will use
photobiomodulation you know we use vibro
acoustic stuff so we use a lot of other
technologies that are many of them are
much more affordable and consumer
friendly that if they need additional
support then you know that's something
that they could use at home you know as
a supplement to kind of help them get
going and neuro meditation Institute
calm is the yesterday yeah neuro
meditation is to.com is a website a
couple last thoughts on the way out
let's ask you if you think were in a
simulation hmm do I think we're in a
simulation wow I wasn't expecting that
question I don't I don't think we're in
a simulation but it wouldn't really
shock me if I found out we were you know
honestly I kind of don't know I'm kind
of agnostic on a lot of those kind of
big issues because even sort of around
spirituality and things like that you
know I feel like I kind of have the
attitude at the moment could change
tomorrow but that everything is possible
that it's all true it's sort of what
element do you want to tune into so
people who are into ascended masters you
know it's like is that real it's like
yeah that's real is that real for me
well not really but that's not how I'm
oriented but that doesn't mean that
that's not
true I mean the universe is a big place
you know which which go you which angle
do you want to look at and so I don't
know I have no idea I don't even know
how to answer your question how about
what's the most beautiful thing in the
world
Wow the most beautiful thing in the
world hmm yeah I can feel it for myself
putting words to it is a whole other
issue right you know I would say sort of
that that feeling of boundless love you
know so it's not a thing right but the
moments that I've been able to touch
that everything else becomes almost
irrelevant and so you know you sort of
understand you know for that moment you
sort of see it all you know and it's
like oh this isn't that hard now staying
in that space of course is quite
difficult yeah I'd have to say that's
the most beautiful thing of all or being
able to sort of touch that space
boundless love pleasure yeah yeah thanks
so much much for coming I appreciate it
next we have initiated thanks everyone
for tuning in
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode also go
and check out Geoff's links below the
neuro meditation Institute comm and also
check out the links below to
consciousness hacking check out the
links below to simulation as well
support the artists organizations the
entrepreneurs around the world that you
believe in and talk more with your
friends your family or coworkers online
of social media about epic things like
mindfulness quiet mind open heart focus
meditations the differences between them
go and practice these yourselves
throughout the day and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon
that simple broccoli pick you up Thanks